[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saludos de unidad riaño
[Música]
durante 2021 eeuu se estima que
enfrentará la mayor ola de emigrantes de
los últimos 20 años aunque la casa
blanca se resiste a hablar de una crisis
migratoria el cambio de administración
tuvo el 'efecto llamada' que bailén
intentó evitar y ahora empiezan a
conocerse los datos de esta nueva etapa
del éxodo el gobierno admitió en los
últimos días que son más de 14.000 los
menores que han atravesado solos la
frontera sur y que ahora están bajo
custodia de las agencias gubernamentales
estadounidenses
valentina torre sánchez nos explica en
el siguiente informe
su prioridad de subir de la violencia y
de la pobreza por ello para sus padres
no importa si tienen que realizar la
travesía solos la administración baiden
informó que son más de 14.000 los
menores que han atravesado sin compañía
la frontera entre méxico y eeuu y ahora
permanecen bajo custodia de agencias
gubernamentales nueve mil quinientos
sesenta y dos de ellos están al cuidado
del departamento de salud y 4500 son
custodiados por la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza
pese a las alarmantes cifras el gobierno
se niega a calificar la situación de
críticas una crisis ocurre cuando una
nación está dispuesta a arrancar a un
niño de nueve años de las manos de sus
padres y separar a esa familia para
disuadir la migración en el futuro
es decir eso para mí es una crisis
humanitaria ya lo que se ha comprometido
el presidente ya lo que me comprometo yo
es asegurar que tengamos un sistema
migratorio que funcione inmigration
sistema de adwords el ejecutivo asegura
que contrario a lo ocurrido durante la
era trump no expulsa a niños que llegan
a eeuu sin compañía y las críticas
republicanas aumentan de estos sitios
donde están los menores son un resultado
directo de las imprudentes políticas de
fronteras abiertas del presidente de
bailén que están provocando un aumento
en los cruces fronterizos y en actividad
de los cárteles en colectivo la casa
blanca ha enviado un mensaje para
disuadir a los migrantes que buscan
llegar irregularmente al tiempo ha
señalado que mediante el título 42 si se
está realizando la devolución a mexico
de migrantes irregulares tanto adultos
solos como grupos familiares para evitar
la propagación del cob y 19
el título 42 es un estatuto creado bajo
la administración trump que deporta a
mexico a todas las personas que
representen un riesgo para la salud
pública a diferencia del gobierno trump
actualmente no se expulsa a menores no
acompañados pero si a familias completas
la práctica es una señal del
endurecimiento del enfoque de bailén a
la crisis humanitaria en la frontera los
migrantes denuncian que no se les
informa sobre las deportaciones solo
fueron a sacarlos en la madrugada y no
los dijeron nada después los dijeron que
íbamos para otro lugar para otra celda
porque había mucha gente ahí donde
estábamos entonces
lo subieron a un avión y pues el pueblo
traía aproximadamente como 400 personas
y cuando nosotros
- acuérdese aparecimos aquí en el primer
puesto de méxico en ningún momento
enfermamos deportaciones ni nada
porque mi niña no conoce su padre y es
que las cifras de la migración hacia
estados unidos se dispararon desde enero
veamos los datos registrados durante la
era by the end en el siguiente informe
de más romeros
vaivén quiere dejar su mensaje claro
seguiremos diciendo seguiremos
enfatizando que la frontera no está
abierta que devuelven a la mayoría de
gente no logran entrar a eeuu y
francamente el mensaje no es no vengan
ahora es no vengan así nunca hartnett
en esta no es la manera de entrar a eeuu
la manera de entrar al país es hacerlo
de manera legal pero para muchos no es
posible y viajan hasta la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu esperanzados por la nueva
administración demócrata que prometió
una política migratoria más humanizada y
revertió las medidas más duras que había
impuesto su predecesor donald trump
después de una caída drástica en el
número de llegadas provocada en abril
por la pandemia la cifra de migrantes
detenidos en la frontera sur de eeuu no
ha dejado de aumentar el mayor salto con
diferencia es entre enero y febrero de
este año un aumento de un 28% en los
meses de transición entre la
administración trump y baiden aunque los
adultos solos siguen siendo los que más
tratan de cruzar la frontera la llegada
de menores no acompañados ha aumentado
un 61 4% y la de las familias un 163 9%
la mayoría son mexicanos pero en febrero
casi se duplicó el número de hondureños
guatemaltecos y salvadoreños que
llegaron a la frontera sin embargo para
estos migrantes indocumentados la
esperanza del gobierno de bailén es
falsa bajo el argumento de la crisis
sanitaria la enorme mayoría son
regresados a méxico - los menores no
acompañados
una crisis cada vez de mayores
dimensiones que ensombrece las reformas
migratorias de bailén
las expulsiones desde eeuu llevan la
crisis nuevamente a méxico donde el
gobierno anunció un cerco sanitario en
sus fronteras norte y sur para
actividades no esenciales aunque la
decisión se atribuye a la pandemia
coincide con el aumento del flujo
migratorio hasta que inmigrantes de
france24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]